So many people dream of seeing New York city one day.
Here we all are, but there are people
who still want to get here.
And our next story is about a nine-year-old
who made it happen.
The Week reports,
Shepherd Colver dreamed of seeing the statue of Liberty.
So this summer he and his dad hopped on their bikes
and they drove on over.
That's right.
They drove all the way from Washington state.
What?
The journey was 3,300 miles and it took 19 weeks.
And it was made even sweeter because their first attempt
was cut short when shepherd was diagnosed with diabetes,
but he's doing great.
And he made it this time.
And I just, I love this story.
It's amazing.
I wonder, you know, I'm so inspired.
Look at them.
You're so inspired to do something amazing like this,
but you know, 3000 miles,
that's a long, that is a big commitment.
And, and I just
I'm proud of them.
I don't know that I could do that,
but I'd love to think that I could do something like this.
This is amazing.
And think about that memory that he has created
with his nine-year-old son, that for the rest of his life,
he's going to think about that time.
He went from Washington, I'm from Washington.
I know!
I know how far the Pacific Northwest is,
and on a bike?
Make it all the way out here?
That is a, give them a round of applause.
That's amazing.
Commitment!
Nate,
would you ever do that with your kids?
You know what?
After seeing that,
and as sentimental as it is,
no, absolutely not, are you crazy?
You crazy?
No, I'd barely go around the block.
I really fear what my kids would do
if I told them this was happening.
I would literally have to get that
young gentlemen on the phone and have him like,
give it real to my girls.
What, what kids do this?
What parents are able to inspire this in their kids?
This makes me feel like a dysfunctional parent
with major aspiration goals.
So good for you, family.
Good for you, no doubt.
(clapping and cheering)
That was incredible.
It's like,
that would not be easy.
No, not at all.
Well, Nate Burleson,
thank you so much for being here.
Thank you so much.
And obviously catch him on CBS mornings.
Every weekday on a show that is just,
we're so proud also to be linked together, you know,
cause in a lot of markets and cities,
it CBS mornings and then us.
So what an honor to be sibling shows,
what an honor to be working with you,
and I just more and more and more.
Yeah, no doubt.
Wake up with us and stay with you guys, right?
Yeah, that's the point.
And we have footballs to throw.
(cheering and clapping)
And good news stories to promote.
(upbeat music)